speaking of it you were kind of
mentioning these sophisticated tools of
analysis well there are some stories
that we can get to the bottom of without
very sophisticated tools or even Minds
which are very analytical watching a
very very special segue happening
just you wait guys I almost stuck the
landing and then you had to make fun of
me at the end of the show eighth rate
his best Segways in his worst Segway
we're gonna make we're gonna make a time
stamp exactly after the show we're gonna
do a compilation of of my best and worst
uh Segways well I'll just drop the name
of the story I'll just drop the title of
the the article here and the story we're
going to talk about uh U.S funded
scientists were among three Chinese
researchers who fell ill amid the early
covid-19 outbreak identification of
three who worked at Wuhan Institute of
virology fuels suspicion for proponents
of lab leak Theory that's quite an
understatement a prominent scientist who
worked on Corona virus projects funded
by the U.S government
do I have to keep reading is one of
three Chinese researchers who became
sick with an unspecified illness during
the initial outbreak of covet 19. and
let's keep it on fortified
so maybe it's whatever Tim has maybe
someone else had to take over his
podcast for a day I have no idea but
what I will say is this we have had a
number of conversations on this story
about lab leak hypothesis first the it
came from a bat that lived a thousand
miles away from where the virus first
sprang up Theory which I guess a
nickname we could give to that a
shorthand it stupid the the insane
stretch I I don't know what else to call
it we have had conversations on the show
about the fact that there are certain
theories
and that we as the American people
didn't have access to because
information was withheld from us this is
an example of the American people having
basically all of the facts that they
needed to have to come to the correct
conclusion very early on but the media
just continually gaslighting people
about drawing the most obvious possible
conclusion the reason the term
conspiracy theorist is so effective is
because what it does is it generates an
image in the mind of the person who
hears that term of an individual who
doesn't go for the most succinct
credible reasonable and simple
explanation but who instead will make
any kind of logical leap or stretch to
believe whatever it was they wanted to
believe in the first place now to me
that sounds a lot more like that
description fits somebody who thinks
that covet sprang up in a population of
bats that live a thousand miles away
from Wuhan as opposed to having come
from the virus Factory where they were
doing gain of function research in the
city where the virus first sprang up
for our good for our good and then you
question science I know I know and and
with details now emerging I mean I I
just have to laugh I'm glad that this
story came out I'm glad that this was
published I think this is valuable
information for the American people to
have did we need this did we need this
information to come to the most obvious
possible conclusion here
uh well I I think it is important that
we start to find out agreed who's funded
by the U.S government including if
Chinese researchers were being funded
and getting sick in were they working in
the the covid uh Factory the Wuhan
Institute yeah they were they were
working at the Wuhan Factory where they
were working on covid and they got ill
being funded by the US government it
smells obviously it's insane it's
notable that it's coming from the Wall
Street Journal right this isn't a fringe
group that's exactly exactly what I was
thinking is that okay is this going to
be another Fox Hat oh no it's not
Eternal it's not Newsmax it's no one who
also so frankly I don't believe it it's
Wall Street Journal but it's not the
whole street journal editorial page
either yeah it's no it's the they are
presenting it as fact they they feel as
though they have the evidence to back
this up and I I can't speak specifically
to the Wall Street Wall Street Journal
but most of these major mainstream
Outlets we can kind of guess what their
track record on this theory yes are they
cited the fact that this is being
reported I mean we are three years out
some a lot of people's attitudes towards
uh the pandemic have really shifted uh
but it's notable that I I'm I now I'm
very Pro you're foreign
they might try to convince the American
people to be in favor of it just so that
they don't have to take accountability
maybe this was a good maybe we needed
this we all get to spend more time at
home
bodybuilder no but
yeah like you're saying maybe we all
already knew this information maybe this
is drawing uh forth the conclusion that
a lot of us had already assumed but the
reason the answer to your question is no
is is that read that last sentence the
identity and role of the researchers is
one piece of intelligence that has been
cited by proponents of the Judgment that
that's actually not very good writing
the opponents of the Judgment that the
pandemic originated with a lab leak and
that is not a an award-winning sentence
but no it's still they don't actually
take the position that this tends to
prove or this proves that it was always
that it was anything other than
a lab League the nature of their illness
hasn't been conclusively proven yeah so
it's just a bunch of facts we're gonna
line up but we can't say what happened
yeah exactly I mean again there's one
extremely obvious Tim would not
appreciate if we got him do you
monetized no no so this is one of those
things you are able to discuss but we
probably shouldn't push out further into
other questions of the medical science
that YouTube would not questioning
science we're questioning them all
sweets
when I talk about the Medical Science
too I think well there are certain
elements of it that you're not allowed
to discuss because that's you know uh
how science works but I know that with
this The Establishment is actually
starting to admit that this is clearly
true that's what I'm thinking this is
what the vibe I get it seems like people
are like okay we've kind of figured out
what happened and now these news
organizations I don't want to speak for
all of them but the ones that relied for
so long on printing newspaper are
failing they don't have the income that
they used to have in there they need to
get to break the story so one of them is
going to be like you know what we're
done with pretense print it print it
first print it before the New York Times
print it before whoever USA Today just
print it first we'll be the guy now yeah
I think you're right there is a in news
media there's a lot of be there first as
fast as you can also this is not a
Democrat
Centric story as such
this is the uniparty this is the Deep
State this is the administrators this is
the big government so that there's a
little bit more
room for that kind of reporting it's not
like reporting on the bidens yeah yeah
it actually makes the US government look
kind of bad which might be good for
other countries so who's behind this
news propaganda I don't know that's the
research who owns The Wall Street
Journal then right I wonder how much
money blackrock's put into the Wall
Street Journal let's find out that's a
good question yeah please look that up
for us right now because that's uh
certainly valuable information I mean I
think I've pretty much made my point on
this that the the explanation here from
the get-go was unbelievably obvious
we've had a number of different people
in media and uh in you know the the
channels of the United States government
and actual like uh official institutions
that people look to as authorities
throughout this entire pandemic come out
and say that they were not either being
honest with us from the beginning but
maybe a better way of putting it is
saying they weren't being truthful
because that doesn't necessarily demand
that we believe that they are being
intentionally dishonest just that what
they were saying clearly wasn't true so
there are certainty against the lawyer
the lawyer the lawyer appreciates me
saying that because you just hit on
something that I actually had wanted to
say before but I've forgotten which was
misinformation information they want you
to miss oh I like that thank you
misinformation
is a made up word
there's disinformation
disinformation is an affirmative attempt
to lie to you
about reality so that you for policy
reasons for political reasons
misinformed I was misinformed they told
me the show started at seven it starts
at eight someone made a mistake or even
someone did it on purpose I was missing
before there was never such a thing as
misinformation I mean there might have
been the formative might have existed
theoretically but misinformation is
something that was created in the social
media era as a term to describe
what might not be true what might not be
truth but to make it sound like those
who repeat it
are engaged in disinformation because
it's rhymes with and it alludes to dis
information but accusing someone of
disinformation is almost saying that
their competent State actors or
something you don't want to say that you
want to say rather that they're
interesting so that that's what a lot of
what we're talking about that's the
theme and do you mentioned this you sort
of mentioned it earlier the idea is to
get across an official narrative
and to put to marginalize anyone who
departs from it as being engaged in a in
misinformation not in misinforming
people because when you misinform people
it's like I thought the movie started at
night yeah exactly people make mistakes
no it's because you're bad yeah no I
think that's a very good point it's a
very good way of looking at it I think
what everyone has to remember here is
the media you know social media
platforms and basically everyone in
government including people in
government who are actually colluding
with social media companies to have them
censor people from those platforms we're
claiming that their interest was in
protecting the American people now if
it's true that you are genuinely just a
seeker of Truth who wants to use the
best information available to protect
people then when your track record ends
up revealing that you have been
consistently incorrect about important
details which you punish people for
speaking truth on you'd imagine some
kind of humility would be demonstrated
and you would loosen your grip over the
control of informational flow or you
would loosen your restrictions and on
some things they have however they still
act with the degree of authority and
certainty which is not only unearned but
what which has been thoroughly
dismissed and refuted by the facts I
would say has been entirely undermined
uh by their own track record it's either
that is that they were uh incompetent or
malicious and either way I'm concerned
with that's why I just don't buy
anything at face value anymore it's
really eroding my will to live I will
admit oh dude like on a yeah like it's
just happening slowly like piece by
piece is coming out of me stone by Stone
I'm like I'm I'm it's getting dark like
the future I don't see a good future in
10 years with this AI Revolution and the
amount of Stranglehold that the US
government seems to be trying to keep on
people like it just admit it sometimes
you know like let it out of let people
live and Thrive otherwise I can't
imagine anything good happening in the
next five years geopolitically I mean
not not nothing but I'm saying
I I don't I mean if if people if they're
willing to shut off people's bank
accounts that are trying to live off the
grid like what the hell are we doing to
ourselves
I'm very concerned man and by the way
the Vanguard group owns 18 of News Corp
which owns uh the company that we were
just talking about the Wall Street
Journal yeah Vanguard yeah man
um I I hear a lot of what you're saying
and I think there are a lot of people in
the audience who probably feel similarly
about seeing a very Bleak future ahead
of them but I mean don't lose your will
to live over it you matter I mean yeah
exactly but Ian
that might be part of it it's too much
coffee
maybe you just got so black pulled by
that information if you work in news
media and you just consume these stories
back to back back to back it's true it
is easy for it to become like you do you
you have to research the show it gets
really dark on the other hand you have
to remember all the things that happen
in your daily life that are worth
continuing to push against the system
for yeah yeah man so I I don't it's just
like a psychology hour if I have kids
what are they going to be 20 years old
and shipped off to the military to fight
some war or or like a defensive nuclear
war like I guess robots what well decide
not to push back I mean that's part of a
part of self-determination right like
you have the free will to be actively
present in the life you have right now
and to do what you can to make the world
a place that you would want to pass down
to your children I think you have to
resist giving up yeah man because you
can't lose hope the The Establishment
actually thrives off of you not having
hope when the people they're trying to
subjugate don't see a path forward
that's when they win that's when they
win and that's part of the attack on
religion yep yeah yep absolutely the
attack on religion and the attack on the
family as well you mentioned something
about children again I don't have any
kids but from every single parent I've
ever spoken to it sounds to me like like
choosing to have children is a
tremendous Act of Hope You're hoping
that there will be a better future
you're being optimistic and saying I'm
gonna bring life into this world because
I think it's going to be a good thing
that that I did it was uh you mentioned
to us before the show that you renewed
your faith in your early 20s was this
idea of Hope and having a path forward
something that did that for you that's a
good question I mean really
you know growing up in what's considered
to be a secular Jewish environment
although it was very strongly ethnic
because of the Immigrant component of my
parents and my and grandparents
you know and then finding myself as
someone whose own parents had not gone
to college and all of a sudden I was at
Princeton so I was in the very precipice
of
in an elite school an elite school and
sort of supposedly the entree into the
elite of the world which is not what I
learned much much later was that these
schools mostly perpetuate that works
they're not there to invite you into
their Network although if you want to
deself yourself enough to really be a
member of the club well that well but
that was precisely that's actually a
Jane Coleman that's my wife's that is my
wife's phrase not that she ever uses it
you know what Woodrow Wilson said the
purpose of Academia is to make a man as
little like his father as possible yes
and that's why his name has been
stripped off every building in Princeton
ironically I think that's honestly I
think that's the one thing he said
they'd probably love right but not sure
not exactly they've moved away from
their ideological father but the answer
to the question is yes I mean
looking at looking at this strong
identity that I had and then looking at
what really assimilating really meant
and the fact that I knew that I I had an
an inherent
belief in God and in the validity of the
Jewish tradition as
being something that was valid and
meaningful to me it what I did was I
went to uh I went to Israel to study and
became much more knowledgeable about my
Heritage and actually took a couple of
years between graduating law school and
starting my career my what would
eventually become legendary legal career
bring some humility to you uh imagine
what it was like before can you just
imagine I don't think I can no actually
it well there's not well that's much
more humbling than being 25 years old
and have a degree from Princeton and
from Law School in Northwest that sounds
really humbling man and no no and then
going to a beginner's Yeshiva in Israel
and learning
basically the ABCs yeah you know stuff
that my kids learned when they were
seven and eight yeah so that was but the
humbling um effect did pass yes yeah I
know of course well and I'll I'll
mention this and I think we could have a
really fascinating uh discussion about
this and about religion and faith on the
after show but this is one thing a lot
of people are deprived of is a religious
education because parents say you know I
want to let my kids choose when they're
older your kid's gonna make a choice
when they're older regardless give them
an inheritance give them a faith teach
them something so that if they do choose
it they don't have to start from square
one like they're they're like a little
kid learning at all for the first time
and my friend from Princeton days yorum
hazoni writes in his books about
National conservatism and about
conservatism
people are under our misapprehension
they think well why should my child be
exposed to our particular religion sure
he has to have religious education but
what makes our families tradition any
more valid stop asking a stupid question
okay it's your family's tradition it's
what made you who you are do you like
your parents do you like your
grandparents if you don't it's probably
because of Freud throw that stupid ass
tradition out the window based all right
yeah we agree on that we definitely
agree we couldn't save more yeah and I
think we'll save more of it one thing I
would say to people when you start
learning about like Christianity and
Catholicism and decide to become
Catholic then don't don't you know feel
free to to not do the same thing
blame the Jews
I want to talk more of the black pill
before and then we can carry the
restaurants because the next story is a
black pill so let's get both of them I
gained a faith in God 10 years ago or so
15 years ago I started to feel it I was
like okay cause microwave background
radiation radio telescopes can see this
web of radiation I'm like maybe this is
God or part of maybe I'm seeing like an
after effect of it or something but then
I'm like okay the last week I was like
oh geez good and evil people are like
good triumphs over evil and all the
movies good triumphs over evil and I'm
like you know what I think most of the
time evil triumphs over good because
it's willing to destroy and then it just
tells people it was the good guy and I
think that's the history of humanity so
even if you believe in God and all these
things that we're supposed to believe in
and have faith it's like then what we're
going to perpetuate this cycle of evil
taking over again and then brainwashing
everyone to think that they were the
good guys it's so pessimistic we'll get
into it on the after show we'll get in
on that show because we have we have
other black pills that I have to feed
people right now otherwise I'd want to
stay on this topic so we will flesh it
out later thanks for watching this clip
from the timcast IRL podcast hang out
with us live Monday through Friday at 8
pm and become a member over at
timcast.com for uncensored members only
show those exclusive thanks for hanging
out and we'll see you all next time